I'm Nicole, I'm the current political action
co-chair of the Black Students Union here atMIT
I really got involved with the political
action last fall. I live in New House and on
my floor in another community in new house 3.
I think someone was just fed up with the state
of the kitchen and there were a lot of dirty
dirty dishes around and essentially they put
up posters with a lot of violent language and it
also included the tired trope of starving children
in Africa and it was about the nature of like
"Starving children in Africa would die to eat thesescraps off your plates"
Often times what happensis the BSU exec will organize an emergency GBM
just to gather the opinions of people. It's also
kind of a check-in like "How are you guys doing, how
does it affect you like -- community, like how are we
doing as a whole?" And then after that we kind of
brainstorm solutions and what we want MIT admin
to do. Like last year I was not the student exec
but I worked really hard on writing the demands
after New House committee because I just thought it was
ridiculous that shit like this could happen. It
was so many nights of meetings and talking with
admin like even though I was choosing to put my
time into it, it's not like another extracurricular
it's not like I'm choosing to go to soccer practice over
doing my homework, it's not like I'm going to like
the business club. I am a black student, I'm
affected by this like instance of race-based
violence. I am calling an MIT to respond. It's
not my fault that I have to do that on top of
being an MIT student. But officially we asked
for a couple things like a public apology,
the discipline made known, the incident made public
to the MIT community. None of that happened [Music]
MIT is a money-making Institution, um in
meetings with admin it's never been hostile
but it feels like we're not being heard. They will
sit with you, um they'll have a meeting with you
have a discussion and then after that either there's
no follow-up or they tell you "Sorry, no."
Like I know Boston is one of the most racist cities in
America-- that's not it. We are on MIT's campus and
in Simmons actually last year a student walked
into a room full of, you know, people of color
and just called them slurs and then walked out. Why
do I have to go through MIT being subjected to this
and MIT does nothing about it. And it's really
hard because people are saying like "Oh you didn't
have to be BSU co-chair, you don't have to get
involved in BSU exec, you don't have to completely
disengage from your identity but you don't need
to do activism. If I don't do it who is going to doit?
Because MIT is not fighting for black students,
and I've heard that from admin, like they will not
act unless we as students push them to act.  So yes,
I don't have to be co-chair, I don't have to be
on BSU exec but that means there will be no place
for black students at MIT, and I cannot have that